our other big story here at 11 o'clock
the raiders thursday night game right at
allegiant stadium the team
really needed a w tonight brian
yeah it was a sign of things to come
when the head coach came out in an
oakland raiders baseball cap john's now
joining us with a little bit more john
sometimes i get changed in the dark too
right so it happens
christmas would come early for raider
nation if their team would win tonight
and be back in the playoff conversation
it would be the greatest gridiron gift
unfortunately coal is often silver and
black the story of the game happened
early and it hurt derek carr took off
running for the end zone in the first
quarter
and left the field wimping he was
holding his left groin muscle
in obvious pain he did not return we may
have seen his last snaps of the season
next man up marcus mariota the heisman
trophy winning quarterback out of oregon
our raider resurrection touchdown strike
to
darren waller raiders lead early
second half las vegas down seven not for
long when this organ duck
takes flight the ninth island coming
alive on thursday night
game is tied and in overtime but in ot
raiders get a field goal chargers
electrocute their raiders defense
justin herbert to jaylen guyton herbert
would reach across the goal line a few
plays later
30 to 27 the raiders fall to 7-7
and crisis level i have a one-track mind
and that that involves winning and
this is going to help us in in some ways
but it's really
really painful right now to lose and
we've had a lot of tight games go down
to the buzzer
and this one was uh this one was tough
but
i am proud of our players proud of our
coaches and
congratulate the chargers the raiders
have lost four of their last five and if
you paid attention to that graphic
tonight was the first chargers victory
inside the
afc west division in two years one
team's mediocrity is another's christmas
miracle